how tough was Dance Moms on its young
cast many of us are wondering since
Maddie Ziegler recently revealed that
her mother apologized for putting her on
the show at such a young age from the
cast members getting locked in a
bathroom to being taunted by producers
this show may have been worse than we
thought we've got all the behind the
scenes details
by now we all know that reality TV is
Far From Reality but with a series as
drama-packed as Dance Moms it's easy to
wonder just how much was actually real
and how much was contrived by Producers
cast members have come out to reveal
that much of the series was in fact
staged and fake dance competitions were
allegedly faked to comply with child
labor laws but there may have been other
reasons too they can't go to a real
dance competition because no they can't
go to a real dance competition because
they can't con anybody to switch the
scores additionally the famous pyramid
was set up by producers the producers
and Abby have a good talk before every
single week and talk about what dances
and newswear and whatever as like the
last season went on it like didn't even
matter where you were on the pyramid so
why even bother with the pyramid if it
has no repercussions they do the pyramid
to kind of like start the drama off for
the week well it just started to be so
nonsense the complete even party like it
fans have also been able to pinpoint
moments where the editing deliberately
LED audiences astray like clips that
were filmed for specific episodes being
used in entirely different places to add
to the drama as for the cast members
themselves the versions of them that
viewers know wasn't entirely true either
why well because it was easy for
producers to push the young cast members
around to stir up drama in the first
season I mean I was seven there was male
producers saying like this is what you
have to say according to Ziegler
producers would ensure that her mom
wasn't in the room in order to keep her
vulnerable to their requests they would
say say you're the best say you're
better than everyone else say blah blah
blah and so I was perceived kind of like
a little brat Maddie Ziegler is one of
the most well-known Dance Moms cast
members there is this is probably why
her recent Revelation during an
interview on high low with emrata had a
major impact on the public Ziegler
recalls that last year she was having a
panic attack and called her mom things
were coming coming up from the past and
she apologized to me and she was like
I'm so sorry that I put you through that
Ziegler noted that her mom would never
have wanted to hurt her and her little
sister Mackenzie who also participated
on the series but none of them could
have anticipated how things would spin
out of control and the lasting effect it
would have on them she really like did
everything to try and break our contract
and pull us out and eventually did by
the time their contract was broken
Ziegler recalls being 10 or 11 years old
show scouted us when we were six seven
understandably Ziegler says that she
doesn't remember her life before dancing
I also have blocked out so much of my
childhood that I actually don't know
what my life is like even just before
working it's no wonder then that Ziegler
doesn't consider much of her experience
on Dance Moms to be positive it's weird
to find out things that I did when I was
younger on like Tick Tock I don't even
remember doing that while it's clear
that Ziegler has repressed some memories
of what we all watched on TV these days
she's focused on doing the work to
reprogram her brain and reject the
perfection she was taught at a young age
my thought process when I was younger
also through my dance teacher was like
you have to be the best and while some
aspects of Dance Moms may have been
faked for the cameras the pressure Abby
Lee Miller put on the dancers clearly
wasn't you're being abused
you want to disappear
you don't want anyone else to know
Ziegler even notes that while she got a
reputation for being Miller's favorite
student this just meant the expectations
that were placed on her were even
stricter I just want to make Abby my
team and my fans proud ultimately
Ziegler is appreciative of her career
that was kicked off by Dance Moms but
she doesn't condone much of what was
done to her things that the show
promoted is very not what I stand for
like having an older woman yelling at
kids in retrospect Ziegler recognizes
how toxic this situation really was for
children I feel like that's obviously
not a great environment and I'm glad
that we've grown up and gotten out of
that Abby Lee Miller's treatment of her
students was clearly one of the most
difficult parts of being on the series
for the children and if you've seen even
just the clips of the show you already
know what we're talking about Miller was
known for being hard on the girls in
fact that was a lot of the draw of the
series in the first place Miller boasted
a reputation for being tough as nails
and having tactics that made her dance
students better while also stirring up
plenty of drama
ha yet it's clear that Miller's
treatment of the girls goes far beyond
that and Beyond what is reasonable when
asked by a reporter for a piece of
advice regarding how to deal with Miss
Abby don't cry if she yells at you don't
contradict her another draw of the
series was how Miller fought with the
titular Dance Moms often loudly and
right in front of the children save your
tears for the pillow don't talk to me
like that I'm an adult right so you
shouldn't be sitting here when asked by
the same reporter how the next season
would stack up to those that came before
they shared a little different it's a
little bit more violent the girls
definitely see the moms fight you know
it's impossible to have them out of the
room every time we're going to argue and
it really does upset the kids clearly
for a series that's centered around
children the adults behind the show
weren't thinking too much about the
children's needs yet the surprising
environment behind the scenes went far
beyond what we saw on screen neglect of
the young cast members was also
pervasive on set in fact craft producers
would deliberately harm the children in
order to create increased drama for when
the cameras started rolling moms from
the show recalled when the producers
locked the kids in the bathroom just to
get a rise out of the moms when they
couldn't find them the girls were
huddled together and crying when they
were found their basic needs were often
ignored as well JoJo siwa is another one
of the famous faces who started out as a
dancer on the series since more former
cast members have come out about their
experience on the series siwa took to
tick tock to discuss her own time as a
cast member okay that is the truth I
don't regret doing Dance Moms it made me
who I am today she did however share one
surprising regret and that is that I did
not watch the movie Carrie Seawall
thinks that Abby Lee Miller was right
about this watching the movie would have
helped her with character development
for her carry inspired routine still
while it's clear that Seawall tries to
stay positive about her experience on
Dance Moms she's had her subtle ways of
sharing how she feels she once shared a
tick tock clip of Miller asking siwa's
classmates to stand in front of the
class and give reasons why Seawall
should be kicked out of the dance
company she used the caption when people
hate to try and hurt me but this was my
childhood in the clip Miller yells at
Seawall to stop crying to which siwa
famously replies
unfortunately treatment from Abby Lee
Miller weren't the only difficult parts
of being on Dance Moms simply being on
television at such a young age presented
its own set of problems Maddie Ziegler
can't believe the things that the public
witnessed her doing on the series that
she doesn't remember herself they almost
know more about my little self than I do
other cast members say that contrived
plot lines resulted in them getting
threats from the public they set up
situations that might have not actually
happened it got to the point where I was
getting threats cast member Kendall has
also been open about how growing up on
camera has affected who she is today it
was definitely tough going through all
of those emotional roller coasters of
like getting screamed at and then
getting praised and then telling you
that you suck at dancing like many of
her castmates she feels that being
taught to deal with this kind of
feedback at such a young age gave her a
thick skin as an adult but being in the
public eye came with its own set of
lessons growing up in front of a camera
it's just such a crazy perspective
because you have to watch what you say
you have to watch what you do watch how
you act cast members recall that Abby
repeatedly threatened to kick dancers
off the show if they didn't perform how
she wanted and they were often kicked
off by producers judges like stressing
and I hear Abby say to the producers if
she forgets this dance she's done like
Abby can't say I'm gonna kick off the
team like it's up to the producers it's
up it's not actually up to Abby and Abby
was the one saying that I was gonna get
kicked off so you may be wondering where
is Abby Lee Miller now well she sold the
Abby Lee dance company but she's still
teaching dance that said she's being
sued by a former student so if it wasn't
already clear in retrospect Miller
students have some pretty mixed feelings
about the dance teacher what do you
think about the treatment these young
cast members received while working on
Dance Moms and what do you think of
Maddie Ziegler's mother's apology let's
discuss this in the comments and for
more behind the scenes details be sure
to like And subscribe to the things